several unemployment claimants have
contacted us regarding money that's
being stolen
off their debit cards and it's happening
to those bank of america cards
joe mohler joining us now live to show
us this headache that's really creating
for them
joe yeah we're coming
across more and more people who are
having this problem and as you can
imagine they are frustrated about it
when they go to use their debit card
the money is missing now unemployment
claimants are issued bank of america
debit cards to access their money
people say when money goes missing they
try and report it to bank of america
usually the card or account is canceled
and any issue is
looked into people say they are having
issues getting that money back
several claimants told me today that
representatives from the bank tell them
that dieter will help they call dieter
and they say it is the bank
we spoke to jodi chavia she called the
bank who told her dieter needed to help
she doesn't know if she will get her 650
bucks back that she says was stolen
i called again today and she said it was
closed and that i would need to reach
out
that um unemployment closed the account
which i checked online and my claim is
still open
it's very frustrating i mean you know
643
may not be a lot to a lot of people but
that is my part of my rent money
according to the organization cal
matters nevada is one of three states
that does not do direct deposits into
personal accounts it is done
by those debit cards over in california
a similar problem has been happening a
lawmaker from the san diego area
introduced a bill there
that would require california's
unemployment department to allow
personal direct deposits to avoid this
sort of problem
now to be proactive and avoid getting
money taken some people say right when
that money hits their accounts
they usually go to the nearest atm and
pull that money right out now i did get
in contact with someone from bank of
america today
uh they tell me that people can actually
log into their account online and set up
an automatic transfer to another bank
account
they say this is all done online if your
card is frozen the first thing you
should do is call that number on the
back of your card and get directions
from someone there
and they say if it is frozen you should
uh the only place that can unfreeze that
is dieter then they have to contact
bank of america and i just wanted a
quick note here on lost wages assistance
we have not received an update on that
as soon as we do
we'll be short to update you reporting
live joe muller 8 news now